who do you think suffered the most from
this so far
the little account holders this is
always true so one of the big
Temptations with fraud I've covered a
lot of scams frauds is everyone looks at
the big number everyone that's the
headline billions of dollars the top 50
creditors or what everyone thinks at
first
uh but quickly when you dig down you
realize that most people who lost 10
million dollars I mean I'm sure that's
terrible for them I wish them to get
their money back but uh it's usually the
people with like 50 000 or less that are
most impacted usually they do not have
the money to spare usually they're not
Diversified in a sophisticated way
um so I think it's those people I think
it's the small account holders that I
feel the worst for and unfortunately
they often get the least press time or
air time that's a really difficult truth
of this is that especially in the
culture of cryptocurrency there's a lot
of young people who are not Diversified
they're basically all in on a particular
crypto
and it just breaks my heart to think
that there's somebody with fifty
thousand or thirty thousand or Twenty
Thousand but the point is that money
is everything they own
right and now
now what their life is basically
destroyed
like you know imagine your 18 19 20 21
years old
you saved up you've been working you
saved up
and this is this is it this is basically
destroying a life
what's so brutal about this is that this
all comes on the back the entire crypto
Market comes on the back of
comes from the deep distrust of
traditional Finance right yeah 2008
everybody lost trust in the banking
systems and they lost trust that if
those banking systems acted in a corrupt
way that they would receive the Justice
it turned out that the banks received
favorable treatment people didn't so
people
lost faith in the the structure of our
financial system in a way that is we're
still feeling the reverberations of it
and so when crypto came along it was
like kind of this way to reinvent the
wheel reinvent the world for the the
like sort of lowly and the like less
powerful and kind of level the playing
field so it's so sad about events like
this is you see that fundamentally a lot
of the the power structures are the same
where the people at the top uh face
little repercussions for what they do
the people at the bottom are still
getting screwed the people at the bottom
are still getting lied to and law
enforcement is way behind the ball
do you think that's really uh
damage people trust in cryptocurrency
for sure way bigger than uh Luna way
bigger than three hours Capital it's
because of who SBF was it's not just the
dollar figure behind it it's because he
wooed so many of our media Elites who
should have been calling him out or at
least investigating him and not rubber
stamping him
it's an indictment of our financial
system or even our most sophisticated
people in Blackrock in Sequoia who
didn't see this coming who also rubber
stamped him
um and you just wonder like if you can't
trust the top people in crypto who are
supposedly the good guys the guys saving
crypto month just a month ago or two
months ago he was the guy on Capitol
Hill that was talking to Gary Gensler to
all the top people in Washington he was
orchestrating the regulation of crypto
if that guy is a complete fraudster liar
psychopath and nobody knew it until it
was too late what does that mean about
the system itself that we're building